this video is brought to you by morning
brew a free daily email newsletter with
the latest business news but in a fun
way click the link in the description
below to subscribe to morning brew today
more on them in a bit he was a bad son a
bad husband's and a bad King but a
gallant and splendid soldier that was
the description that historians Steven
Runciman thought best fitted Richard the
first this was in line with the
criticism brought against Richard by
Victorian scholar William Stubbs who
considered him a mere warrior who had no
care for his kingdom or sympathy for his
people
indeed Richard the first was an absentee
ruler spending only a combined six
months out of his 10-year reign in
England the rest of the time the king
was either involved in Wars or in
captivity or simply preferring to reside
in his French territories such as Andrew
and Aquitaine today scholars debate
whether the king even knew how to speak
English or not as he preferred his
mother's language of Austin and yet
English history remembers him quite
fondly he was after all Richard the
Lionheart but was he truly deserving of
this moniker we'll let you decide that
for yourselves as we explore the life of
King Richard the first
[Music]
Richard was born on September the 8th
1157 in Oxford England he was the son of
Henry the second king of England's and
eleanor of aquitaine very powerful and
influential woman in her own right who
prior to her marriage to Henry also
served as Queen of the Franks as she had
been the wife of King Louie the seventh
before their marriage was annulled
Richard was a part of the House of
Plantagenet ooh-rah dynasty that ruled
over England for approximately 330 years
his grandfather in fact Geoffrey the
fifth count of Anjou was the one who had
founded the house while his father
became the first Plantagenet to claim
the English throne it was generally not
expected that Richard would become King
as he was the third son of Henry and
Eleanor the eldest son William died
young before Richard was even born
his other older sibling though Henry was
the one ordained to follow in his
father's footsteps
in fact in 1170 the family made an
unusual move for English royalty and
crowns the fifteen-year-old henry as
titular king of england while his father
was still alive he became known as Henry
the young king to help distinguish him
the coronation was in name only and the
elder Henry still retained authority
this became a bone of contention between
father and son as the young Henry grew
frustrated with his father giving away
possessions that he considered to be
rightfully his it was spurred on by
other noblemen both English and foreign
who wanted to get rid of the elder King
and even his own mother who had a
falling-out with her husband this led to
the revolt of 1173 to 1170 for young
King Henry had powerful allies including
the aforementioned King Louis the
seventh and William The Lion King of
Scots
he almost managed to secure victory but
in the end Henry the second was
triumphant so what role did Richard play
in all of this well by the time of the
uprising he had already been made Duke
of Aquitaine region of modern France
which back then was a Duchy that became
an English possession when elder Knut
married Henry it was also the place
where Richard spends a lot of his time
both as a child and as an adult and
which by all accounts he seemed to
cherish far more than the whole of
England Richard actually sided with his
sibling during the revolt
as did their younger brother Jeffrey of
course he was still a young man at that
point and was clearly being influenced
by other people most likely his mother
and King Louie of France in fact after
that rebellion had been put down Henry
the seconds imprisoned eleanor of
aquitaine to keep the boys in line and
still minimize her influence on them she
would stay under lock and key for the
next 16 years as for his rebellious sons
Henry was merciful and forgave them
after they submitted to him richard
retains that title of Duke of Aquitaine
and his father tasked him with the
punishments of the nobles who rebelled
against the English King Henry's orders
were for most castles in the Duchy to be
reduced to the state they were in 15
days before the start of the uprising
but he specified that some of them
should be completely razed to the ground
obviously this did not sit well with
some of the local noblemen who refused
to stand down and continued their
rebellion against Richard Henry placed a
lot of trust in his eighteen year old
son and his military prowess as he gave
Richard full command over the duchies
armies as well as control over local
revenues perhaps he was impressed with
how Richard handled himself during the
revolts even if it was against him
certainly
Richard would develop a reputation as a
great fighter Arryn's military leader as
opposed to his older brother Henry who
was described as giving no evidence of
political sagacity military skill or
even ordinary intelligence Richard spent
the next few years as his father's
regions in Aquitaine putting down
rebellions we have knowledge of his
efforts courtesy of the 12th century
chronicler roger of hardin the young
Duke made special mention of his
successful siege of Castilian sua as
Jean it was heavily fortified ins
required the use of artillery but after
two months Richard managed to break the
garrison clearly he was quite pleased
with himself as it was arguably his
first impressive military triumph these
successes started establishing his
reputation as an adept commander but
also his penchant for cruelty as he
showed little mercy to those who stood
in his way
some Nobles proved to be bigger
challengers than others the rank on fire
they for instance were a major thorn in
Richards site they were Lords in talib
are led by Jeffrey to Rankin and their
castle was considered impregnable built
on a rocky outcrop on the right bank of
the charan River it was unassailable
from three sides while the fourth was
heavily fortified Richards strategy was
to make himself an irresistible target
so that his enemies would leave the
fortress and come to him he destroyed
the village that was nestled beneath the
Citadel he began burning down the
surrounding fields he even placed his
camp close enough to the castle walls so
that Rankin would consider a surprise
attack meanwhile be deployed artillery
to make it look like a standard siege
then he just waited sure enough his
enemies launched a counter-attack but
were defeated by the Dukes army
Richard's men were then able to force
their way into the castle and after
three days of looting and destruction
Rankin surrendered this was truly a
notable victory so much so that upon
hearing of it other rebellious noblemen
decided that the fight was not worth it
and also laid down their arms in front
of the Duke of Aquitaine
peace throughout the lands did not last
long many historians of that time all
said that Richard was a cruel man who
oppressed his subjects with unjustified
demands and a regime of violence all the
nobles hated him so much that they
banded together to try and drive him
away from the region and even sought the
help of philip ii of france eventually
king henry had to intervene and he
ordered henry the younger to come along
as well again
roger of Hobbiton gave the most detailed
account saying that the Barons complains
that Richard took their wives and
daughters by force to satiate his own
lust and that when he was done with them
he gave them to his soldiers we don't
know if such accusations were true but
it did a matter because Henry saw
nothing wrong with them
like father like son I suppose he
subdued the rebellion and 1182 and
returned to England the nobles saw
another opportunity though while
Richards and King Henry could not be
reasoned with perhaps they could appeal
to Henry the younger almost a decade
after his failed revolted past and he
had no lands to claim as zone while
Geoffrey had Brittany and Richard had
Aquitaine of course in time when his
father died he would have claims the
whole of England's but Henry was
impatient when the French barons
promised they would recognize him as the
new Duke the idea of invading Aquitaine
was firmly implanted in his head all he
needed was an excuse that would appease
his father that excuse came in the form
of a castle which sat on the border
between the lands of Richard and King
Henry a castle that Richard had spent
time repairing and reinforcing Henry
wanted it and the king ordered the Duke
of Aquitaine to give it to his brother
as homage Richard refused and his
brother invaded his lands with help from
many Aquitaine Nobles younger brother
Geoffrey also joins the invasion against
Richard although first he tried to
remain neutral the elder King Henry
eventually sided with Richard even so
the war was not going in their favor
Henry the young king was poised to win
but he fell ill suddenly and on June the
11th 1183 he died of dysentery marking
the end of the rebellion Richard was now
heir to the throne his other brother
Geoffrey also died in 1186 allegedly by
being trampled during a jousting
tournament there was only one other
brother remaining the youngest of all
John who so far had not taken part in
any of his family's political and
military mashaa nation's contemporary
chroniclers claims that John was his
father's favorite not very hard to
imagine seeing as how he was the only
legitimate son of King Henry who didn't
raise his sword against him because
Richard was now poised to rule over
England's and other territories such as
Andrew and Norman dear King Henry wanted
to give the Duchy of Aquitaine to John
Richard refused his Aquitaine was the
territory he cared about most perhaps
even really the only one that he cared
about for a while it looks like it would
be war again between the Plantagenet but
Henry had an ace up his sleeve he
finally released his wife Eleanor of
Aquitaine from prison she returned to
her homelands where she was the rightful
ruler and Richards who still had great
affection for his mother willingly
surrendered all power however he found a
new ally in king philip ii of france
also known as philip augustus there were
tensions between Henry and Philip over a
marriage that fell through and they
escalated to violence
Richard officially paid homage to Philip
and sided with him against his father
that you owe were also triumphant and at
the same time the older Henry fell
gravely ill after he was defeated henry
was forced to recognize richard as sole
heir he died two days later on July the
6th 1189 and Richard became the new king
of England now just before he continued
today's video I do want to take a moment
to tell you about today's sponsor
morning brew so what is morning group
well it's your morning coffee but it's
also a free daily email that gives you
the latest news from Wall Street to
Silicon Valley it's a five-minute read
and it will keep you right up to date
with the latest at the front of the
business world think business news can
be dry and boring well yes it often is
but it's not if you've got morning brew
it's witty its conversational it's even
actually funny now I suppose to talk
about how it fits into my morning
routine but my
it means it actually comes around
lunchtime so usually I end up reading it
while I have my lunch which is also nice
so click the link in the description
below to subscribe to morning brew today
just do it you'll enjoy us and it's free
and let's get on with the video Richard
may have been the new king that's he had
no time to concern himself with matters
such as running his kingdom he adds a
crusade to get - ever since 1187 when
Sultan Saladin founder of the ayah bird
dynasty had captured Jerusalem the Pope
had been calling on the European powers
to launch a new crusade and take back
the Holy Lands and by the way if you
would like to study the topic in depth
and see it from the other perspective we
have already done a bar graphics video
on Saladin you can check that out
through the link below there were three
major powers involved in the crusade
England's and France led by Richard and
Philip and the Holy Roman Empire led by
Frederick the 1st or Frederick
Barbarossa
there were of course vassals such as the
Hungarian forces led by Prince Kaiser
and the Austrians
led by Duke Leopold the 5th King Henry
the second was actually the one who
pledged his service to the crusade or
taken the cross as it was called but he
wasn't exactly enthusiastic about the
cause he was old and frail into plenty
of things backing him to worry about but
public opinion eventually pressured him
into joining there were actually
preachers and minstrels back then that
would walk into villages or town squares
and rally the people to take the cross
they used propaganda pictures such as
images of Christ being struck by an Arab
soldier or of his tomb being trampled by
a Saracen Knights and his horse peeing
on it Richard needed no such persuasion
nor was he doing it out of obligation
like his father
we can all say how devout he truly was
but he was a soldier looking for a fight
and back then there was no greater fight
than taking down Saladin and recapturing
Jerusalem he did apparently have some
kind of religious experience on route to
the Holy Lands and became overcome by a
need to confess his sins and renounce
his wickedness he summoned all the
bishops stripped himself naked Neal's
inference
of them and began flailing himself with
whips before all this though
Richard needed money to raise and equip
an army for the crusade prior to his
death is a father enacted a new tax code
called the aid of 1188 or better known
as the Saladin tithe Phillip in France
did something similar
King Richard also began selling official
positions and other privileges while
also forcing those who already held such
titles to pay a tidy sum in order to
keep them as you could imagine this did
not sit well with many of his countrymen
both rich and poor Richard have little
concern for them though as it was often
said that he looked at England's not as
a kingdom but as a source of money and
soldiers according to legend when
someone complained about the Kings new
money-making schemes he declared that he
would sell London itself if he could
find a buyer Richard left for the
crusade in the summer of 1190
accompanied by philip augustus who led
the French army his first stop was in
Sicily where Richard sought to resolve
an unrelated matter the previous year
King William the good of Sicily had died
and his cousin Hank red had become the
new King tank red also imprisoned
William's Widow and denied her
inheritance as it happens that Widow
Queen Joan of Sicily was Richard's
sister unsurprisingly the English King
demanded that his sister would be
released and given her inheritance
Tancredi refused so Richard captured and
plundered the capital of Messina
eventually the two Kings signed a treaty
and this was mostly notable because it
prompted Richard to assign an heir it
wasn't his younger brother John but
Arthur of Brittany the only son of his
dead brother Geoffrey who would have to
marry one of King tankards daughters
speaking of marriages Richard himself
needed a queen and while he was in
Sicily his betrothed arrived she was
Baron Gary a daughter of King Sancho the
wise of Navarre this caused problems
with his French Ally you might recall we
previously mentioned that King Philip of
France and King Henry the seconds of
England had a falling-out over a failed
marriage that marriage was supposed to
be between Richards and Philips
half-sister Alice it had been arranged
while the two were children and Alice
came to live as Henry's court until she
came of age however both
and Richard kept delaying the wedding
according to sordid rumors henry had
taken alice as a mistress and richard
knew this sans did not want to marry her
anymore
philip and richard managed to reach a
settlement to finally break off the
marriage but the two left sicily at
different times richard set off with his
fleet across the mediterranean in april
1191 however he encountered a great
storm which destroyed some of his ships
the vessel which carried his sister and
his wife to be shipwrecked on Cyprus
where they were taken prisoner by Isaac
M nos the tyrants who ruled over the
islands Richard successfully secured the
release of Joan and Berengaria but
commonness refused to return the large
treasure which had also been aboard the
ship
obviously he was feeling confident in
his position but fate was against him
Richard invaded Cyprus and conquered it
not only did he get his treasure back
plus all the stuff he looted on top of
it but he later also sold Cyprus to Kiev
loosen your a--they format King of
Jerusalem while on Cyprus Richard
married Baron garrier and the new queen
returned to her native home she became
known as the only English Queen never to
set foot in the country because it was
believed she never visited England's
although it is possible she may have
done it after Richard's death the two
never had any children although Richard
did father an illegitimate child named
Philip of cognac whose mother remains a
mystery
after all the detours and distractions
were finished Richard finally arrived in
the holy lands in the summer of 1191 the
port city of Accra was the first target
of the Crusaders and it fell pretty
easily in fact Richards main problem
during this crusade was not his enemies
but rather his allies he and Philip were
already on the outs not only over what
it happens previously but also because
the French King wanted half of Cyprus as
Philip fell ill he decided to return
home after the fall of Accra then there
was the Holy Roman Empire and its
vassals the King Frederick Barbarossa
had actually died already by this point
in not really the most dignified way he
didn't perish in glorious battle but
rather he drowned crossing the Salif
River in modern-day Turkey some sources
say that the old king tried to brave the
current single-handedly but others
specify he was thrown off his horse and
he was too weak and his armor too heavy
to get up again either way his death
caused many German soldiers to return
home and left Duke Leopold of Austria in
charge
Leopold's and Richard did not get along
and the latter greatly insulted the
former after the Duke hanged his banner
in triumph alongside the English and
French ones after the battle at acre
Leopold's and Richard did not get along
and the Lasser greatly insulted the
former after the Duke hanged his banner
in triumph alongside the English and
French ones after the battle at a crap
Richard felt that as a vassal Leopold
was being arrogant so we had the
Austrian banner torn down in reply the
duke of austria took his men and went
home
the crusade lasted for another year
Richard had other successes particularly
at the Battle of Asif where he scored a
decisive victory despite being taken by
surprise and being heavily outnumbered
this was perhaps Richard's greatest
triumphant it allowed him to retake the
city of Jaffa Richard now had the upper
hand against Saladin but again he was
facing troubles from his own camp
many of the men grew tired of the fight
and the French soldiers that Philip left
behind simply refused to obey him any
longer furthermore disturbing reports
from back home said that his brother
John was making a play for the throne to
rob it all off Richard fell ill with
scurvy perhaps for the first time in his
life the war obsessed King acted
practically he concluded this he would
not be able to keep Jerusalem
even if by some miracle he managed to
capture it so he opened peace talks on
September the 2nd 1192 Richard and
Saladin signs the treaty Jaffa the
Christian Crusaders didn't get much but
it was the best they could hope for
under the circumstances obviously their
main objective of reclaiming Jerusalem
had failed but the treaty guaranteed a
three-year truce between both sides
allowed the Crusaders to keep Accra plus
a small part of the coastline and
promised safe passage for Christian
pilgrims Richard needed to return to
England but was weary of traveling
through Philips territories as by that
point the two were openly hostile to one
another he sailed on the Adriatic but
his ship washed ashore in Venice while
passing through Vienna and his retinue
was discovered and captured by Duke
Leopold who also had plenty of em nity
of the English King he turned him over
to the new Holy Roman Emperor Henry the
sixth who imprisoned Richard and asked
for a humongous ransom for his release
John of course had no interest in
securing his brother's release but his
mother Eleanor started immediately to
raise the money she did this of course
by taxing everyone to the bone and
confiscating treasures and property
after over a year in prison
Richard was released in 1194 it returned
to England where he was crowned again to
further establish him as king in a
rather strange move Richard not only
forgave his brother John for revolting
but also named him as his new heir
perhaps Richard simply wanted to calm
things down in England so he could
refocus his attention he was already
ready to go on the warpath again this
time against France during his
incarceration Philip that conquered
Normandy and Richard he wanted it back
King Richard left England less than a
month after his second coronation never
to return again he reigns for another
five years but he spent all that time
warring with Philip only interrupted by
the occasional truce
Richard's crowning achievements at that
time was the construction of Chateau
Galliera
new castle which was considered a
masterpiece ahead of its time perhaps
fitting for a man so obsessed with
warfare King Richard's demise did not
come against a mighty foe such as
Saladin or Philip but rather while
fighting some
peasants he was suppressing a minor
revolt in the region called Lima saw and
had besieged a small unassuming castle
named shalosh Cabral
Richard was patrolling the perimeter and
inspecting his men paying little notice
to the arrows occasionally firing at
them from the castle walls he appoints
even mocked the artists fate does not
like to be tempted like that so of
course a bolt from a crossbow hit the
king in the shoulder right below the
neck richard was taken to his tents
where he collapsed the wounds was poorly
treated and develops gangrene according
to the chronicles of Roger of HA Verdun
the shooter was a boy named Bertrand
whose father and brothers had been
killed by Richard the King allegedly
showed mercy and ordered that the boy be
set free and given a hundred shillings
it is unclear if his order was followed
though some sources claimed the King's
officers hanged Bertrand alongside
everyone else in the castle King Richard
died two weeks later
on April the 6th 1199 by his mother's
side as mentions in his avatar the lion
was slain by the ant so I really hope
you found their video interesting if you
did please do hit that thumbs up button
below don't forget to subscribe also
please do subscribe to morning brew
today's fantastic sponsor you will find
them linked to below and thank you for
watching
[Music]